what is the healthiest food you can
possibly eat you got it
kale
perk up it has 35,000 international
units of vitamin A that's perk up that's
like 10 times the vitamin A of any other
vegetable it has potassium vitamin K
it's loaded with all sorts of
phytonutrients those are plant-based
chemicals that prevent cancer and really
will get your body healthy so I'm going
to show you how easy it is to get kale
in your body and we're going to make a
kale shake and I have probably three to
five hundred thousand people in the
Washington DC area doing this kale shake
okay now there's two types of kale one
right here we have the regular kale the
green kale right here which I kind of
like the best but then you have the
dinosaur kale which is flatter Leafs
right here so we're going to just do
this with the regular kale you're going
to take a couple weeks and I see a
handful the stems and all just stick it
in there okay so we're just going to
pack it in there maybe like three stems
okay so we're going to stick it in there
pack it down like that and then we're
going to take some blueberries now you
can take any fruit I have like a half a
cup of blueberries handful of
strawberries you know just like that
okay so that's pretty much the
combination then we're going to just
take water filtered water and I'm going
to just put this right above the kale
not all the way up I like it a little
bit thicker you don't have to put ice
cubes because it's frozen this fruit is
frozen you can put a banana if you need
it to be sweet I don't like it too sweet
and plus if you're trying to lose weight
you don't want to add a banana
unless it's green because it makes it
smooth the other thing that you might
want to add is coconut oil no this is
not something that I really tell a lot
of people but you take a teaspoon of
coconut oil coconut butter and put it in
there now you have this incredible
smooth shake okay so we're just going to
okay now the key is three minutes okay
or more because if you don't blend it
for that long what happens is it gets a
little bit chunky so you want it really
really smooth you can use Vitamix is you
can use all sorts of high power blenders
I just use a regular cheap blender it
works great and if you want to wait till
it settles down you can do that as well
but this shake is incredible so I do is
I'm going to actually just put it to
test this out I'm going to have our
camera guy test it out so let's manual
let's go ahead and let's go ahead and
see what you think about that and I'll
see if you ever had this before I've had
the one from the office never okay tell
you to think about this one
it's a subtle fresh good yeah it's not
bad is it I mean it looks kind of
greenish brown but it's not bad so
you're drinking you're infusing your
liver with a tremendous amount of
nutrients and vitamin A what's going to
happen it's going to go into the liver
and through the whole skin the mucous
membranes and the sinuses you're going
to breathe better you're going to get
more oxygen if you have a like a lot of
acids in your liver it's going to flush
it out it has so much nutrition you need
to do this every single day do it in the
morning and you have maybe a 2 eggs with
that or go ahead and do it at night
right when you get home from work but I
highly recommend the kale shake check it
out and then send me your success
stories